regresar a casa para celebrar el año del
buey a pesar de un viaje repleto de
restricciones contra el kobe 19 o
quedarse solo en beijing como piden las
autoridades
el dilema atormenta a los chinos que
trabajan en la capital
echo mucho de menos mi casa pero por
otro lado tenemos que pensar en todos
así que he decidido no volver esta vez
vientos
el año nuevo lunar que este año que el
12 de febrero es la fiesta más
importante en china y normalmente
cientos de millones de trabajadores
aprovechan la oportunidad para regresar
a sus provincias de origen sin embargo
la alcaldía de la capital pidió este año
a los residentes que evitarán los
desplazamientos innecesarios una
dominación de todos los pasos y luego no
podemos volver a nuestra ciudad natal
pero paradójicamente en un momento así
la gente parece querer reunirse aún más
en familia y espera valorar mejor el
tiempo que pasen juntos
sabangan transición y acción como para
evitar que los chinos viajen beijing ha
prometido dedicar 6 millones de dólares
en cupones de descuento para los que se
queden en la capital también ofrece
películas en línea y paquetes de datos
móviles para celulares y está
funcionando los viajes en tren y avión
han caído un 80 por ciento respecto al
año pasado
después de superar todo eso espero que
el próximo año podamos vivir y trabajar
con más optimismo por el momento los
viajeros que entren en beijing deben
presentar una prueba pcr
y luego someterse a otras dos pruebas
siete y catorce días después de su
llegada unas medidas que podrían ser
endurecidas al iniciar este año del buey
asociado para los chinos a la
perseverancia y la paciencia